we all have fantasies some people think
about winning the lottery others imagine
a world where phone bills don't exist
and some of us dream of a day where our
games stop screwing us over but every
now and then in sports and eSports
fantasy does become reality the stars
literally align and something special is
born super teams are an exciting
prospect on paper we expect them to be
successful but the potential for how
they win is really what gets us going
sometimes though what we get doesn't
live up to our expectations and in
competitive gaming no team sums up that
kind of disappointment more than see
esko's phase Clin back in 2016 when
harambe broke our hearts and weiner
jokes were finally turned into a feature
film faze clan made headlines in the
counter-strike world by dropping
reportedly $700,000 on the roster of g2
esports not long after the big money
acquisition phase began fiddling with
the lineup in pursuit of building a
dream team joining rain was Kerrigan
that October followed by nico in early
2017 in hindsight it was sort of like
buying a Lamborghini only to realize you
actually wanted a completely different
car that also happened to be a
Lamborghini that don't make no sense
while the team did make some Finals
appearances under Carrigan's leadership
they crashed out of the pgl major in
Krakow that summer that has to be
highest expectation and worst outcome
that I've seen in recent memory as a
major which meant only one thing it was
time to throw even more money at the
problem
joining Rayne Kerrigan and Nikko came
Guardian one of counterstrikes all-time
best offers who is still hunting his
first major title after spending years
falling short with Navi
alongside him arrived olofmeister 2015's
best player in the world who had won
multiple majors during his time with
fnatic Ashley the timing just as he goes
to plant the bomb for the noscope cuz
you can't commit too much there he goes
it's the first one now he has to plant
this bomb he actually pulls the fake
this was a real super team on paper they
were something to fear
they were basically see ESCOs version of
the [__] avengers and I think this
both is a matchup change that's good
it's a firepower potential upgrade
that's good and it changes the map pull
in a key way that might allow you to win
out against SK and become the number one
team in the world to say that faze fans
were creaming their genes at the time
would be an understatement it's over
guys
Olaf and Guardian on top of Nico
Kerrigan and rain just give us the major
now baby am i right guys
however with great expectation comes
even greater pressured and a Dreamhack
Malmo in September face had their first
chance to show the cs community what
super teams were all about but things
didn't go exactly according to plan I
can't believe what we're seeing rain is
hiding behind here are they gonna spot
it out there coming in he goes for the
spray but gets taken out almost dropping
a trend and now it's on all of my stuff
at 16 seconds left they're gonna go for
the bomb pound here one versus three he
certainly has the talent for it but
they're all over the place it seems like
it's meant to be for gambit all of
breaking out and now they're gonna try
and go for it mo shot him down it's 1613
gambit face seriously drop the ball on
that last map they had multiple
opportunities to close that game out to
have anywhere even bigger lead and even
bigger advantage and they just failed
miserably the delicious cake that the
phase recipe promised to be needed more
time in the oven but in spite of their
slow start to 2017 phase finally began
collecting trophies showing fans exactly
what they were capable of in the
[Applause]
[Music]
oh so happy down and outs of Dupree
getting that kill Kerrigan doing the
best he can with the firm assets two
versus three with 17 seconds of somehow
Bay's managed to hold on to the bomb
site here ten seconds for flavor and
it's not enough Harrigan is a hero those
grenades going off there's one left on
six we'll see if he gets it in play it's
not looking like it the other get cut
down in droves
reign old Meister there's Kerrigan
chiming in it's all on device now 1v5
but not for long reign he has mercy
these early dominant performances and
tournament victories created a ton of
hype around the roster convincing some
that the scenes new overlords had
arrived during this period phase
groupies in particular became especially
unbearable hey man Colin is driving me
up the wall today why what's he doing
that hey Colin do you know what time the
meeting is today yeah man it's phase
o'clock [__] okay anyway after
dominating the latter part of 2017 face
at their sights on kicking off the new
year with a major title in Boston and
while they made it to the events grand
finals with relative ease
only one of them really showed up when
it mattered
guardians doing what he always does in
the mean time
oh well that is a shot and a half from
Jordan that's making the only chance
Baconian comes back in oh god idiot -
there's still more to go boo
can I must pop the ball the peeps come
in for Guardian will not stop one more
to go
and Guardian yes then all automatic in
the pool rain take it out two on two now
and his tarik he's got high to help but
it's not perfect
down he goes it's Guardian he's the only
man standing between cloud lion and the
major it's gonna be a double peak the
first ball we go every time number two
they're still anticipate that despite
Guardian playing out of his mind
cloud 9 ran away with the series in a
butt clenching overtime it's Guardian
purpose to me to Annie Kenney to this
position before the wind phase around a
very important very crucial uncanny
denied cloud nine I'm sore from this
position before you cannot miss a single
shot Guardian waits patiently as cloud
my steps a push up
[Applause]
Oh
hey Colin
how about that grand finally I'd rather
not talk about it
are you drinking yeah is there a problem
it's 10:00 a.m. on Monday yeah well you
know what they say it in it's five
o'clock somewhere
much like dating profile pictures
consistency was hard for face to find
while there were occasional flashes of
brilliance in 2018 and the team hoisted
silverware at a number of events there
were also tournament performances to
forget against lesser competition as
well we won't player waiting for Dan
that's gonna be next one of these kills
might just guarantee absolutely
everything he's done damage can he find
anything more needs backup can't get it
the bomb has gone down and tizian left
in the two or more he's got an m4 picked
up Hillman he's got the hole
[Applause]
this inconsistent form left fans
wondering about the team's chemistry and
this was the first problem with this
faze clan roster it was filled with
superstars who despite Kerrigan's
efforts were often essentially playing
pub style CS all of my stuff versus
three players he doesn't have a defuse
card and if there's one on the way as to
fake a flashbang just to get around one
corner but your fan girl from Samia will
be enough and that is a wipeout batch of
dust - 16 - 5 Vic clan winning both
pistols and being comfortable from start
to finish it's just it's baffling right
you don't like faze obviously have had
struggles in the in the past before but
for them to start this flat like nobody
individually looking like they're on
point it doesn't seem like they feel
like a team at this point this
individual centric approach might have
worked during the same era fnatic
dominated but the times had changed
you're living in the past man the
adherence to a tactical system was part
of the modern csgo landscape individual
skill was still obviously important but
it couldn't be a long-term crutch as it
turned out faze clans roster was less
like the Avengers and more like Norman
Osborn's Thunderbolts venom bullseye and
radioactive man might kick ass
individually but together they're kind
of a mess ok shut up we can't know for
sure whether Kerrigan was unable to
bring these players together in a
coherent tactical system or if they just
simply refused to adapt but if his
previous and later teams are any
indication it came down to challenges he
faced with the players he had that is
the problem in skilled teams that even
if you have five skip lists you can make
it work as long as one player is making
it's the final boss of the team so if
said let's go B if we all go B and we
just die as a team or we win as a team
unfortunately for Kerrigan he'd be the
one to pay the price he was benched and
then shipped off to envyus on loan
before permanently leaving phase four
mousesports in 2019 you can't just have
five superstars play us and nobody
really take the leading role so
and failing to replace Carrigan would
prove to be the second major problem for
phase 2 remedy the situation the igl
role was filled by a dren and then later
neo but even under those seasoned
leaders phase never managed to return to
their late 2017 form they understand the
game to such a level they can play the
game to such a level
how does when you mash them together how
do they meet strife how do they meet
struggle why is this happening I just
think it's about time that face finds
the guidance right they find a line they
want to follow in a long long time we
haven't really known what faces anymore
shows to me it wasn't just Kerrigan like
removing Kerrigan didn't make faze clan
better it made them worse a mac-10 for
neo versus three can you get around the
corner he can't do it
renegades take it they survive and they
eliminate faith clan from the major
there's one more thing to consider
though the interpersonal situation now
everything that Kerrigan era team told
us in interviews made it sound like
things were working out great but super
teams by nature are made up of big
personalities and sometimes that can
lead to differences of opinion and that
begs the question how much sense does it
make in csgo or any other eSport to
build a team of superstars you need to
find five players that you can sign that
are not on the contract anywhere else
they all have to be socially matched and
they all have to be willing to play
different roles I the likelihood that
you can find that is very very low even
then how many players are superstar
players for like a year you know almost
nobody is so if you if at the time you
sign those five players three months
later some of them are gonna be in a
slump and then what's the point
but despite the unlikelihood of all
these variables falling into place and
their willingness to try out the
relatively unknown brokey phases most
recent marquee signing coldzera is
further proof that they're not ready to
give up on the super team dream Rhodian
CTB called one step ahead very aware
he's very much tuned in
the third misses it by a hair's length
brokey will get dealt with it's cold
though and it's the cold show cuz
they'll get a four-phase 15 rounds at a
small that mods face while this new look
Nikko led phase hasn't exactly stormed
out of the gates it's still too early to
label their superstar experiment a
complete failure the organization
clearly believes that their formula is
capable of creating a dynasty but is it
really a blueprint their fans can
believe in honestly I think the answer
has been under phase clans nose the
entire time look there's this guy on
reddit years ago making a case and I
think it's time to try and move wait a
second you're not talking about big dong
Danny the one and only
isn't that your alt account no no no no
no it's it's not yeah ride for Ferrari
yellow Lamborghini I don't know I've
never heard that until you just said it
is that a suicide door I know what the I
know you're talking about I don't know
that was what they're called please
please help us